I mean you never hit a ball like damn
it's his bomb and you hit the same Bowl
later but at the end you're like dude it
tastes hot like it tastes like lighter
fluid like a chemical a little bit it's
because you're sucking through that
flame put it this way I can close my
eyes hit a bowl and I'll tell you if you
use Hedwig I used to rip everything
resin with lighters
oh crackling resin [__] rather not smoke
weed without heavily yeah like after the
lung infections I got in my 2015 from
all that those packs my lungs are like
[__] they're sensitive it's like
walking on an asphalt Barefoot like oh
that's how I feel like oh I need I need
shoes that's how I feel it is it flushed
it's not flush it tastes bad like I'm
such a [__] now bro but I also smoke
the [__] fire now
[Applause]